シェイクの
ストロベリー
こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
お肉を禁止して約1か月
お肉自体ほんとねそんな好きじゃないから
焼肉とか行きたいとか特になんないんですけど
でも
俺がマックで食べれるのはせいぜいエビフィレオかフィレオフィッシュぐらいなんですよ
いやだぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ！！！！！
どうしてもビッグマックが食べたくなってしまったんですよ
うわぁぁぁ
ビッグマックマックハンバーガー食べたいけどお肉が食べれない
俺はどうすればいいんだあぁぁぁ
って思ったんですけどもお肉抜いちゃえば良いんじゃねという事で全メニューお肉を抜いて貰いました
こうやって見ると結構種類ありますね
今マックで売っているハンバーガー全種類でございます
そして全て牛肉鶏肉豚肉抜きとなっております
つまり普段なら絶対食べれないですけれども
今の僕はここにある物なら全部食べるという設定でございます
いぇい
１８種類のハンバーガー全てお肉抜きで準備して頂きました
まあビックマックも食べたいんですけども
ここで僕が知りたいのは
お肉抜きのハンバーガーで一番美味しいハンバーガーはどれか検証していきたいと思います
全部お肉入ってないすからね
ひょっとしてこれによって
そうすれば僕は今後マックに行ってもそのハンバーガーお肉抜きで頼んだら美味しくハンバーガーを食べられるんじゃないか
つまりもう僕は合法的にハンバーガーを食べられるわけですよ
ええやん
というわけで早速やっていきたいと思います
何か全種類お肉抜きでお店に頼むとか
何かすごい迷惑行為みたいだったので
事前にお店に電話して
マックさんに準備していただきました
ご協力ありがとうございます
では早速食べていきますか
まあまずは普通にハンバーガーから食べたいところではあるな
ハンバーガー食べていきましょう
やばい薄い薄い薄いし中が
...
まじかー
もうピクルスバーガーと化して
いただきます
これで美味しいかもしれないんだよな
うん
なんかねホットドッグの肉抜きって感じっす
全然食べられないってことはないですわかんない
最初の一個だからかも知れないですケチャップがいいですねぇ
続いてこれはお決まりと言ってもいいでしょうチーズバーガー
食べていきましょう簡単な話さっきのハンバーガーに
チーズを乗せただけの所であるんでー
大きな変化はないのではないかと
またもやピクルス
んんwww
えなんかお肉抜きでも美味しいんじゃねっていう説が湧いてきたぞ
チーズとケチャップで味が成立してるんでぜんぜん美味しいです
うまぁぁぁぁいっwあっ全部うめぇかもしんねぇこれぇ
次ダブルチーズバーガー行きますまぁ考えることは一緒でしょう
たぶんねチーズが一枚多くなってるだけなんだなぁ
あっピクルスが二枚になってるうれぴい!頂きます
一緒
ベーコンレタスバーガーベーコンが抜いてあるのでぇ
レタスバーガーと言っても過言ではない
オープンプライス！
ほんとにレタスしかねぇなぁ
後逆に健康思考でいいのではないでしょうか頂きます
あぁこれは良くないなぁ
だって今までケチャップがあって食べれてた気がするんですけど
やばいレタスだけだとほんとにちょっと
ぉぇ
次はチキンクリスプ行きましょうチキンクリスプからねぇチキンを抜くとねぇ
もうクリスプから残らないんですよね
はみ出すぎじゃないクリスプバーガーどうなってんでしょうか
レタスバーガーじゃないそうかクリスプもなくなるのか
マジただのレタスバーガーじゃんこれ
やべぇケチャップの重要性に気づいてしまいますねぇ
ケチャップないとほんとにちょっと
続いててりやきマックバーガー
照り焼きのあの液体がかかっているかがポイントですね
無いやん..
同じやんやばい
もう食えな生姜焼きバーガー